será una verdadera batalla por
reemplazar a boris johnson la sorpresa
de la jornada ha sido la eliminación de
penn inmortal quien durante la semana
pasada y está aparecía como la gran
favorita con ritchie sunat pero las
negociaciones de las últimas horas le
dieron el pase a la final a lis tras la
secretaria de asuntos exteriores
británica que se ha vuelto muy muy
popular dentro del partido por su
gestión en la guerra contra rusia la
guerra en ucrania richie zona es un
economista de origen indio formado en
los eeuu él y su esposa aparecen en la
lista de las personas más ricas del
reino unido entre tanto listas es
diputada desde el año 2010 tiene amplia
experiencia en diferentes cargos en el
gobierno además representa la derecha
dentro del partido conservador y aunque
votó en contra del president el 2016 es
la garantía del partido de que este se
cumplirá y con ella podría entonces ser
tercera primera ministra mujer en la
historia británica ahora el turno es
para las bases del partido conservador
unas 200.000 personas que tendrán que
votar hasta el 2 de septiembre en 3 unac
y listas para el nuevo jefe del partido
conservador y por ende primer ministro
tanto zona como lista se inician durante
el verano estas seis semanas una gira
por todo el país para dar a conocer sus
propuestas y entonces ganar los votos
necesarios para convertirse en el nuevo
o la nueva primera ministra